good afternoon blues lovers
rock and roll lovers and music lovers
all to the national press club my name
is sonja hilgren
i am president of the national press
club and editor of farm journal
i'd like to welcome club members and
their guests in the audience today
as well as those of you watching on
c-span or listening to this program on
national public radio or the global
internet computer network
before introducing our head table i
would like to remind our members of
upcoming speakers
on wednesday that's tomorrow keith
lockhart conductor of the boston pops
orchestra
next wednesday january 31st richard
holbrook assistant secretary of state
will speak about bosnia and the future
of europe
and on wednesday february 14th john h
dalton secretary of the navy will speak
about the state of the navy
transcripts and audio and video tapes of
press club luncheons are available by
calling 1-800 npc npc2334
the national press club is also pleased
to announce the publication of a new
book the national press club's best
contemporary speakers
a book containing 13 of the best
speeches made during 1994 to order a
copy call 1-800-211-4020
if you have any questions for our
speaker
please write them on the cards provided
at your table and pass them up to me i
will ask as many as time permits i'd now
like to introduce our head table guests
and ask them to stand briefly when their
names are called from your right
joseph polikov washington correspondent
for jewish newspapers
james brosnan memphis commercial appeal
paul berry news acre wjla tv in
washington andy mosher foreign editor
washington post
reggie stewart assistant news editor
knight ritter newspapers
sydney seidenberg mr king's manager
we'll pass over our speaker for just a
second
peggy roberson freelance journalist and
chair of the national press club
speakers committee
larry seidenberg guest of mr king and an
attorney in washington dc and the son of
sidney zeidenberg
doris margolis
president editorial associate editorial
associates a member of the national
press club speakers committee who
arranged today's luncheon larry lippman
palm beach post member of the board of
governors of the national press club
michael lowe assai shimbun
and bob westgate a freelance journalist
[Applause]
today's speaker
recently celebrated his 70th birthday
and i think probably one of the greatest
bashes ever held
but the schedule he keeps would
intimidate most people half his age
b.b king known as king of the blues is
on the road
250 days a year
he comes to our podium fresh from a
stint in new york city last night he was
on the david letterman show
and flew here this morning to be with us
goes on to las vegas and atlantic city
from here and then it gets really
interesting he heads for moscow he's
going to play at the kremlin palace
and dozen more cities in hungaria
austria spain
mallorca belgium germany poland and the
netherlands
riley b king was born on a cotton
plantation just outside the mississippi
delta town of indianola
he used to perform on the street corner
for dimes
in 1947 he picked up his guitar and with
two dollars and 50 cents in his pocket
hitchhiked north to memphis to pursue
his dream
within a year his popularity had soared
to the point where he needed a catchy
name
and what started out as beale street
blues boys was shortened to blues boys
king and eventually b.b king
our speaker has been singing playing and
defining the blues for six decades
in 1984 he was inducted into the blues
foundation hall of fame and three years
later into the rock and roll hall of
fame two autobiographies one on
interactive cd-rom
are slated for release this year the
cd-rom one is already out the book comes
out later this year
mr king's distinctive style of combining
traditional blues jazz swing and
mainstream pop has had a major influence
on such other artists as mick jagger
eric clapton bon jovi sting and u2 and
that's just the short list mr king's own
very unique land of texas and
mississippi delta guitar blues was
influenced by three of the blues greats
t-bone walker elmore james and lowell
folsom and i think that's the short list
too
the list of honors and awards
accumulated by our speaker is huge
and includes seven grammys a
presidential medal of the arts from
president bush in 1990 an american
heritage fellowship award from the
national endowment for the arts in 1991
the naacp blues image award in 1993
and a kennedy center lifetime
achievement from president clinton just
last month
and all of this has been accomplished
with the help of his sweetheart lucille
his guitar
mr king has performed throughout the
world
he has more than 50 albums to his credit
and has given generously of his time in
trying to help others in addition to
performing dozens of free concerts at
correctional facilities and prisons here
in america he is a co-founder founder
together with attorney f lee bailey of
the prison program known as fair that's
down stands for foundation for the
advancement of inmate rehabilitation and
recreation
back in 1970
mr king received a grammy award for the
song the thrill is gone and he sang that
last night on david letterman
today the thrill is here at our podium
ladies and gentlemen the thrill is not
gone it is here today with us
please join me in giving legendary blues
guitarist bb king a warm press club
welcome
uh madam
president and
of course
madam
robertson the chairperson
of the speakers committee i'd like to
say thank you very much and you ladies
and gentlemen thank you so much for
coming out to
hear me make all the mistakes that i
usually make
i'm really not a speaker as some may
think
and i think lucille played a joke on me
today i had
a speech i thought i had wrote out
and lucille slept on it and
so i've
i'm only left with some notes that i
made
first i would like to say that it's
really an honor to be here
and
to be invited to
just talk a bit about one of the
subjects that i think i know a little
bit about i've been trying to play blues
now for about
50 years and
i think i know more about that than
anything else other than lucille
i'd like to
talk about the origin of the blues music
as it was told to me
and of course
the uh
well i'd start by saying that the slaves
was taught christianity in the beginning
and the master thought that
teaching the slaves christianity and
all
the ways of christ that this would calm
them somewhat and
make them more
obedient
and some of them went along with that
but many of them found that the families
was being sold
and some of them
well the christian families as well as
the non-christian families was being
sold and separated so
they kind of rebelled a bit and started
to sing and play their
music
that they thought
they enjoyed more
well
at that time
these songs was not always about
suffering
some of it was about anger being there
and
not being able to do some of the things
that they wanted to do so
the cotton pickers and when i think of
cotton pickers i was pretty good as one
growing up i used to pick over 400
pounds pick
480 pounds i think was the most and that
was because if i did that
my uncle which i lived with at the time
would allow me to go to town that
evening and
sit on the corners and play the blues
with my guitar
at the time i was uh
also driving tractor which was
one of those
i guess most prestigious jobs we had on
the plantation
and it paid more money than anything
else 22 and a half a week
which was really good i hadn't heard of
the word superstar at that time
but that's what i was
thank you
then going to town on saturday evenings
sitting on the corners playing just
playing and have my hat sitting out
there where people could see it
and as i played people would come by and
generally
request tunes
and the people that request tunes to
sing gospel songs
would always praise me highly they would
say
great son that's fantastic keep it up
you're going to be great one day
but they never tipped
but usually people that would ask me to
play a blues song would always tip me
and maybe a beer from time to time
so you can see why now starting out to
be a gospel singer
i decided to be a blue singer
i uh
i also would like to go a little further
and about the blues
the cotton pickers i should say
they would sing and play melodies and a
lot of times chant them together now
this is
a way of kind of
being motivated i guess themselves
but they usually would keep one lookout
sort of like a century out on the
end of the field
the rose of the cotton if you will
cotton grows pretty high in mississippi
where i grew up at
and you could easily hide a bit if you
wanted to
in fact
many of us did
as much as we could
but this sentry or this lookout would
always be the one that would say
start saying hey
the boss is coming
better get up now
well
that uh person would sing so low and
sing it so good sometimes that kind of
fooled the boss he never knew what was
really going on he knew something was up
but he didn't figure it out
in time because
this guy have alerted everybody
with the melodies that they were saying
and some of them got so good with this
that they would party every night
when they get off work without
the boss knowing about it
and the best of them
sing
their songs to self-made instruments
like i first started my first instrument
was
my self-made guitar that i put on the
back porch
and i had
a string of wire wire string that
some of you probably saw brooms that you
sweep with
this wire wraps the straw around this
this pole that you use for the handle
anyway i had one of those and i'd
stretch it up put a nail up at the top
and a nail at the bottom you take a
brick and put it between it
so you had that one string and that
lucille invis that today
but that's how i got started really
i i think that
instruments of that kind some had kazoos
some had combs that they would put paper
on the combs they would blow that and
they made a lot of music even if it was
patting themselves like this
many different types of rhythms they had
at that time gospel music of course was
pretty strong but blues was
the stronger in the area where i grew up
only difference was in the rhythm
was the lyrics
i guess you could call those singers
then
rappers of that time
i'm not so good at rapping today but
they was pretty good i think the blues
hollers and all this led on to
people like
lonnie johnson blind lemon jefferson
robert johnson and many of the people
that i heard as a kid when i grew up
and i think i'd like to say that i'm one
of the disciples of the people that
made the music pop popular during the
20s and 30s
and of course during that time we had um
one white
person
that was very popular in mississippi
named jimmy rogers
some of you probably have heard of jimmy
rogers
but he was he was so popular that a lot
of the blacks liked him and that wasn't
you know that was sort of like
an unusual thing
but my aunt she was a big fan of jimmy
rogers and i used to hear
his records when i'd go and visit my
aunt
she'd let me play a big troll we didn't
have electricity in the area
in fact we didn't have electricity until
i was about
18 years old ready to go in the army
but we played music
um
today
there are quite a few
white players many more i think today
young players blues players that is then
there are black
blues players
that is what i find when i go around the
country and around the world
but at that time we didn't have but one
or two we had cowboy singers like gene
rory rogers archer
a few others that used to yellow blues
but
not many of them really went out for it
too much
uh
now you can see why i said i'm not a
speaker
i'm still trying to get my my knees to
calm down a bit
but i think it's going to happen
the black blue singers doing the um
20s and 30s
that wasn't very popular out of the area
especially they they didn't make a big
impact i should say
on society
until later when the
british groups for example
the rolling stones cream
uh the who
when these groups started to play blues
in the u.s
then it started to really become
a very popular type of music
and it opened the doors for a lot of the
black blue singers and blues musicians
like myself
some a bit bitter about it but i'm not
i'm kind of happy about
having groups like that to say that they
listened to bb king
and others like myself
which made doors open wider for us
they could get radio play they was
seen on television
and quite often they would mention
people like myself and others
and of course that made things even
better but i started to think then i
said
there must be a better way for b.b king
to get a little further than where i am
now
so i started to look for and i found a
great
artist manager if you will and director
and from that time he um
put a put together promotional plan that
have taken b.b king and his music
around the world we've played more than
50 countries
we've even played
we played the soviet union when it was a
soviet union and we played china a few
years ago
and all of this has really helped and
brought things kind of
today where
we can feel a little comfortable saying
that
the blues is a music that a lot of the
young people and young thinking people
support today
i find the audience around the world is
generally from 18 to probably 45
and some maybe my age or close to it but
but as i said they are young thinking
people and this is
kind of where the blues music is today
we noticed that after the
groups like the rolling stones the the
cream and
the who i should say cream in the hoop
after them uh corporation the big
corporations started to coming out then
supporting the festivals
they've supported the rock and roll
festivals a lot a lot of the jazz
festivals and the blues as we play it
we were able to fit right in we was into
a lot of those uh festivals and that in
itself have made bb king known a little
bit more thanks again to
god and sid seidenberg
this guy and i've been together now for
30 years
um
to add a little bit more to it his wife
is a dear friend and one of my greatest
supporters
she got angry with us one day
we was going someplace she wanted to go
and
sid thought it was a kind of a bad place
to go and a bad time to go and he said
no to her
she didn't like it very much
so she looked at him and she looked at
me and she said b
she said um
i sleep with him every night but you
married to him
so we've had a good marriage for 30
years and
into the blues
we've done a lot
with it
but i i noticed that we still haven't
got to the place that i'd like to be in
speaking of where i'd like it to be
when we walk down the streets quite
often we find that at least i find that
i meet a lot of young people
and a lot of the
players especially the white players
will say i play the blues
and a lot of the young black players say
i'm a musician
i'd like for them to be associated if i
could
make that point with them a little bit
more and
quite often i
i'm asked for autographs
i know most times uh i'm treated
with greats of respect
but generally when the white kids ask
for an autograph they usually ask for it
for themselves
and quite a few of the young blacks will
say
my mother loves you
my father is crazy about you i heard you
all the time when i was growing up may i
have your autograph for my mom please
well it used to bother me a bit in the
beginning
but not anymore i know that they mean
well
but i think
that the white kids if you ask why i
think it's like this
i think that a lot of the white kids
haven't been told as much about b.b king
as the black ones were
and a lot of the black kids felt that it
was sort of a put down to be
part of blues music and a part of that
of that history if you will
and that makes it a difference and then
they don't get a chance to hear it
much like um
they did when it was at home and
speaking of
uh a lot of the people that were fans of
black fans of mine and usually to clear
that a little bit if i can
my audience was never very young when i
was growing up it was always my age
seemingly
and older
and now after i've gotten 70
many of them are near my age and some
are not here with us anymore so a lot of
black kids don't get a chance to get
exposed to bb king
today like
the white ones does
and
in closing i'd like to say that
i'm
if i had to give a state of the union as
somebody is going to do
i would say that the blues is live and
well
and more popular today than it's been
since i've been trying to play it
and i thank you for listening to me
thank you so very much
i noticed in uh looking at all the
countries in the world where you have
performed that you did perform one year
in yugoslavia i think 91 maybe i believe
it was and uh so a questioner says now
that there is peace in bosnia when will
you and lucille play there when you were
in yugoslavia were you in sarajevo
sarajevo
uh
i don't know what it was called at that
time but
we were there
and we also played a peace concert there
since they've been having problems i
believe
and when i'll go back again
hopefully they'll invite me next year i
hope so
you played instagram
that's what sydney says his memory is
better than mine
in all your travels
in every corner of the world which
countries of the world are most
receptive to the blues and where are the
audiences the largest
today
uh it's hard for me to answer that
question because every place we go
today it is
pretty near the same it's almost like
asking me what food is better
cheesecake or just plain cake
it's all good to be in
um
i i really can't answer that but the
audience seemed to be pretty near the
same a few years ago it would have been
different to go to to france or to
uh england or germany
or japan those cities was
really into blues music seemingly more
than anybody else but not today today
it's pretty near the same around the
world
[Music]
you told us about
the
probably
lack of popularity among young blacks
can you think of anything that can be
done to make blues more popular among
young blacks
yes i think so i think that
even though
i i don't think i got into it as much as
i should have about the blues music not
being
aired as other types of musics are today
i think
that the schools today
could be a big help in teaching
young people about the history
of america other than some of the
history that they're not to don't don't
misunderstand me i don't mean to disband
other types of history but to include
uh the history of american music and
this is truly american music if this is
taught
in the schools
if it's
aired more on
a radio
i don't think it's hardly a city around
very few that have blues programs and as
many blues lovers around
uh but they're the the the
the
the radio stations
television station you see on tv you see
vh1
but count the times that you see one
that blues
with the exception of a few superstars
we've had like robert craig the late
stevie ray van you don't see any and
some of us have been out here long
enough and known very well around the
world i think that we
we
we would be uh well accepted
but why have other blues artists not
attracted the
wide popularity that you have
they didn't have a manager like sydney
seidenberg
what new artists in the blues areas have
you heard and liked and would you uh
recommend are quite a few of those um
there's a young canadian called jeff
healy
there's an american named joe lewis
walker
another one is robert cray
little jimmy king
and a young australian
about 13 years old at this time that is
very good very very good his name
nathan cavalieri
what advice would you give to someone
even younger than those new artists to
children who want to follow in your
footsteps
first i would say if you're in school
stay in school
go to college if at all possible
major in
business of some kind computers or
something that leads to that and mine
and music if you will and
practice
[Applause]
wynton marcellus at a recent appearance
here at the national press club says he
hears the blues in country music heavy
metal music even asian music
do you agree yes
yes very much so
five years ago this may you opened your
club on beale street in memphis
you said you wanted to help make the
street uh come alive again
um has that happened in your view yes it
has happened
we uh
kind of
patent ourselves on the back today to
say that we have revitalized middle
street
the blues of 20 and 30 years ago
had more hope uh often was was more
often than not music of hope today's
blues
is a music of despair what's happened
well i think that
the way everything is going now we have
both
um
times have changed
to get a message over years ago i always
use a lady
for example
nobody loves me but my mother
and she could be jiving too
[Laughter]
but that today is different
you have more things i think that a
little bit
easier to say than
you know really being put down that low
do you think it's necessary to have
known the blues personally to sing them
well
no not necessarily be i've had
white players in my group for many many
years got a base play of the day and
this family uh
very well off family
and he didn't have to go through what we
did i've had
a keyboard player his family was very
wealthy from the boston area
and he played blues as well as any other
keyboard
player i ever had
so i said no you don't have to know
about the blues i've picked cotton or
any of that
to play the blues
but it helps
is eric clapton an authentic bluesman
i think of eric clapton as a great
guitarist to me he is the number one
rock and roll guitarist at this time
and he plays blues as well as i do and
better than most
you credit white artists with raising
your visibility didn't you resent the
fact that the public did not accept
blues performers on your own merits
no not really i remember playing uh
beaumont texas
hey
thank you many years ago
uh it was a young player at that time i
was having big trouble with the irs
i was having big trouble may i i can't
continue
i was having big trouble with the irs so
i was playing this club in beaumont
texas
and about five white people come in and
one was
blonde long blonde hair came in and i
said to myself oh god
here they are again
but they came in and had a seat sit down
and was very nice
everybody was and i'm wondering when are
they going to call me off the stage
but then finally one of the men of the
group came up and said
we have a young man that would like to
set in with you and i said oh no man
this is the way i make a living i don't
let nobody come just sit in
he said well he don't want to play much
but he just liked you so much and he'd
like to sit in so then i started to
think about it
if i was in a white club and wanted to
sit in with a group
and they didn't let me sit in i might
think they was not letting me sit in
because i was black
so b you better think about this
so i did and i let him come up
he came up and played one number and the
black people stood up
they'd never did that for me
so i asked him to do another tune and he
did
and when he came off the stage i
remember telling him son if you keep
doing what you're doing one day we'll
meet again someplace and
about six or eight years later we was in
new york at the filmo east
and i saw this same young long-haired
blonde kid
walking and the kids in the audience
start hollering johnny will beat bb king
so no i was never bitter
while working in west africa this
questioner says i met african musicians
who said that the blues evolved from
african tunes and rhythms
uh you have met uh
west african musicians i'm sure yes uh
if so do you see elements of the blues
in their music
uh no they're social though
very soulful
but i didn't hear blues in the music
and
i think that
the blues music
really started in the southern parts of
the united states
yes i'm from the south
now i know that you have told this story
i bet you've told this story
tens of thousands of times but please
share it with us
tell us about the origins of lucille
okay
thank you well in 49
i used to play a place in
in arkansas called twist arkansas i know
a lot of people laugh when i say that
but there are there is such a place
and geographically speaking it's about
45 miles northwest of memphis tennessee
so i used to play this little place a
little nightclub
quite often and then in winter it got
quite cold
uh in twist arkansas so they used to
take something like a big garbage pail
set it in the middle of the floor dance
floor that is
half fill it with kerosene they would
like that fuel
and that's what we use for heat
people dancing gently would dance around
it you know when you're young you do
some foolish things
but one night two guys start the
fighting
and one knocked the other one over on
this container when they did it spilled
on the floor when it spilled on the
floor it looked like a river fire
and everybody started to run for the
front door including bb king
but when i got on the outside then i
realized i'd left my guitar and then 49
believe me keeping a good guitar was a
hard job people would borrow without
your permission
anyway i went back for my guitar and
when i did
the building was a wooden building
burning rapidly and it started to
collapse around me
so i almost lost my life trying to save
my guitar
the next morning though we found that
these two men was fighting was fighting
about a lady
that worked in the little nightclub
i never did meet her but i learned that
her name was lucille
i named the guitar lucille to remind me
never to do a thing like that again
[Applause]
now i i learned about this watching
david letterman um
what happened then to the first lucille
she was stolen in brooklyn what what
were the circumstances around this
i hate to admit it but i went up to see
a girlfriend
and while i was up visiting the
girlfriend in brooklyn
i don't know it might have been her
ex-boyfriend but somebody went in the
trunk of my car stole my guitar
that's how i got i lost it that was
lucille the first and how many lucilles
have there been i'm now playing lucille
the 16th and i was just given the 17th
one
on my birthday their 70th birthday
and i usually sit the seventy i mean the
six seven seventeenth one on the stage
now and
still play lucille the 16th and let
lucille 17th learn what 16th stream
now where are those 14 lucilles
we know one is gone where are the 14.
many other
many of them have been
busted up in automobile accidents i've
been in 18 automobile accidents
and some of them was busted up in them
um
i've given away a couple
to people that i thought was great
musicians that needed a guitar and i've
had a few others that was
borrowed without my permission
are there any in
any hall of fame uh locations or uh
well yes hard rock cafe or planet
hollywood or any place like uh we
haven't made planet hollywood yet
but we do have one the bb king blues
club and we do have one in one of the
hot rock cafes
i think we have one in the hot rock cafe
in tokyo as well
why pray tell were you in 18 auto
accidents
i'm a pretty good driver i've never had
one myself
always somebody else dumped me out
now
also about guitars when did you switch
to electric guitar and um
what qualities do you prize most in a
guitar
maybe what i don't know if you talk
about brands what brand guitar do you
prefer gibson
gibson is the one that i uses now
and where i lived until i was about 18
years old we had no electricity so i got
electric guitar when i fought to play
one with electricity
and that was after 18 years old but what
other qualities do you prefer do you
like in the present at the time
oh
it's sort of hard to say i like them
with the neck
not um
i've got big hands i don't care for the
neck being
too large i like the neck to be
kind of long
and it's sort of like
my favorite lady i like one that i can
hug
that
i just have to go through here and find
this other question since you said where
is it gosh
something it was a really wonderful
question about ah yes since you said
about hugging a lady
in a recent article in the atlanta
constitution you said everyone has loved
someone more than they have been loved
is this from your personal experience if
so tell us about it
i
i don't know how to answer this but
i um
i truly believe that most people that
are in love
most cases feel that they love
more than the partner does
at some times
uh and a lot of times i think that's
when we kind of
feel a little bit insecure maybe
and we will think that way it may not be
true
but i've been divorced for 25 years so
i'm no authority at this time
what is the source of your vitality i
mean how can you do this year after year
215 nights on the road all the things
you're doing a cd-rom a book
appearing here today
what's your secret
you got me again
i i love to play music i enjoy playing
i i didn't finish high school only went
through the 10th grade uh in high school
and i've found that i'm learning all the
time each day is
a new day that's something i learned i
always feel that a day is lost if i
don't learn something new
and to get out and
meet people see people in
not only the usa but around the world is
always refreshing to me and educational
to me
and it's like coming here today
i know and you know that i'm not a
speaker but i
i enjoy so much just standing up here
being able to talk and seem like you're
interested in what i may have to say
that's energetic to me
and to see you
being so nice to me this is good for me
it really is i i thank you thank you so
much that's how i get it
[Applause]
does your new book uh that is still as i
said being written
does that have a message
yes it it it will tell a lot of things
that i've never told anybody
even us and not even you
yes we we talk we get into quite a bit
of detail about
my music uh the learning to play it how
my technique goes and
uh
exciting things that have happened to me
during my
you know time of playing and
uh many many things that generally
people don't ask me and i would just
like to kind of let them know
uh some of these things some of them are
quite personal
now and also your new cd-rom this is
fascinating because as we all know
they're mostly 10 year olds who are
better at computer things than you know
people who are 40 and 50 and years up
and so how did you happen to come out
with a cd-rom before your book it's a
pretty hip thing to do
well uh i've got a hip manager
i get back to him again uh i don't know
how that it really started actually
but i've been fooling around with
computers for quite a while and we
talked about cd-roms and next thing
cd-roms rather next thing i knew sid was
telling me that he had a deal
with the company that would do a cd-rom
and was i interested and i'm naturally
interested i'm so good with the
computers today until
several authors have written books about
me one is called the dummy
and the other one is idiot
so you see i don't know very much about
the computers at all
what is the nicest thing about the
cd-rom i was kind of intrigued with lucy
you can deal with lucille in there and
then you can like uh
have the experience of driving your your
bus and what else tell us about it well
when you first turn it on i'm sitting on
in the on the seat in the bus i should
say and it's my first bus and i call it
big red and so when
i introduce myself when you turn it on
and tell you who i am and
i talk about
how you can find places uh to go by
taking your mouse you know and
that's and touch over here there's a map
and
you can drive can't you
and
probably you will say yes
and we take off from there and i'll be
able to show you um
the area where i came from indianola
mississippi uh
bill street in memphis the clubs in
memphis get a chance to show you uh club
in las vegas i mean not las vegas la uh
los angeles the hollywood area
and then you get a chance to see
something that most people didn't know i
used to fly airplanes i'm a pilot
uh got licensed in 63.
uh because
they stopped me
stopping from flying when the big bopper
and the oldest reading few of them was
killed it made me promise that i'd only
fly
then if i had a qualified pilot so i
don't fly anymore unless i get with
wayne smith over here
um
uh there's one other interesting place
in this uh cd room it's called lucille's
place
and that's out in cyberspace
that's the best i can tell you
back here
in the here and now what was the
inspiration for your standard sweet 16.
well during this time sweet 16.
um
well nationally i think everybody old
boys at least have remembered that
the sweetheart it's when she was 16.
but i think during this time uh we
wouldn't get many records played and
i had been singing this for a while and
i
remember
uh they used to tell us all black
entertainers if you if you you had to
play the howard theater in washington
the royal
theater in baltimore and the apollo
theater new york and if you didn't play
those three you really wasn't and hadn't
been
shall we say christian
as an entertainer
so i played the howard in baltimore
played
i mean the howard in washington and went
to baltimore to play the royal theater
and i remember that when i was
introduced the kids booed me
they did
and that hurt quite deeply
uh and i i knew why though because my
band was playing for the big shows on
one of these big shows but the kids
didn't know anything about bb king only
that he was a blue singer and that
wasn't something that they was
interested in so when they booed me i
remember getting on stage and i started
to play
sweet 16
which i was going to record again later
on
one couple of the lines was in there
that went
uh
you can treat me mean
but i'll keep on loving you just to sing
but one day you'll give a lot of money
to hear someone call my name and i was
crying so
that gave me sweet 16.
and i felt pretty good afterwards
well since you've had
i don't know if i want to say difficult
but you have this relationship with
these kids a lack of appreciation what
do you think about the raunchy lyrics of
rap songs that the kids listen to
i think a lot of the rap entertainers
are great
you try
rhyming everything that you say and
you'll find out that they're very
talented
but i
i think that the four letter
words i think of that as i would a movie
where it's nudity in the movie if it
calls for it then give it
but if it doesn't call for it don't just
say it just simply to
make another word
in fact i prefer a full letter word
g-o-l-f
what's your handicap
what mean what's your handicap all the
way i don't play any
g-o-l
would you like it i like to watch people
like pope and others oh like okay
here's somebody else who says live at
the regal is my favorite blues album do
you have any particular memories of this
1964 show in chicago
yes i do
it was a sunday afternoon and i was
willing to get off
take my wife out i was married at the
time and it was a great audience the
type of audience that you don't get too
often
and um
i think the producer was
there and of course the ranger was
johnny paid and we had quite a few other
people but it was it was exciting to me
and quite often the critics say that's
my best
and i never
disagree with my critics when it's
positive
which of your albums is your favorite
and why
my favorite album
is called my kind of blues
but i uh
i don't think anybody bought it much but
me
can you describe the memphis music scene
when you were coming up what was beale
street like then and did you and the
other blues artists hang out together
well at that time
you could get
15 cent worth of chili
you could get a nickels worth of
crackers
and you could get a nickel's worth of i
think it was a company that made
soft drinks called barge
and you could get uh
[Music]
one of those so you could make a whole
day for about a quarter
of you know food all day uh the
musicians then
blues musicians
associated quite a bit with the jazz
musicians
i had a chance to meet
uh with some of the better musicians
that was traveling like coming
from the north south and from south back
north east and west
and beale street was sort of like a
college of learning
i learned more there
than i had learned in many many years
before i came
how would you describe sam phillips the
adventuresome memphis producer
he was a first
he was a first because i had never been
in a studio before his studio
and he was a good engineer i think
i say i think because i didn't know much
about it at the time but he did get
the music and the voice on tape so he
had to be very good so like a good pilot
quite often people say uh
do you how do you know a good pilot and
i say it's one that can talk with you
still alive
anyhow
mr phillips was a very very good um
good engineer i think at the time
what got you interested in playing in
prisons
we played in chicago we just mentioned
the
the album that we did chicago uh live at
the regal but we we we uh kind of
integrated a jazz club there in chicago
called mr kelly's
so uh
we went into mr keller's and at the same
time it was a black director
just appointed to the cook county
correctional institution
so he called me and said be it's the
first time for you and mr callus it's
the first time for me over here so why
don't we do another first you come over
and play for the inmates
at the prison uh the
cook
cook county uh
jail if you will
and i thought about it and i
i called sid and i said sid i think i
want to go over and do this what you
think i should do so sid said
uh you should invite the press you
should invite another artist and invite
the company our company uh to record it
so we did that and the press interviewed
a lot of the
inmates that was there and most of them
was young people
about 70 of them was young black people
uh
that had been arrested and just there
they hadn't came to trial some couldn't
make bail
so when the press interviewed them
the chicago papers the major papers
plated up real big that next day that
while in the jail when they came to
trial if
found guilty or not it wasn't
compensated for the time
so later on one of the tv networks did
an in-depth story on that and they
changed the system somewhat and that
made me very happy and i decided then i
should do more of it
what have you and ethely bailey learned
about rehabilitation
try to stay out of trouble
it is well known that in the golden age
of blues black artists were often taken
advantage of by the recording industry
do you think the industry has done
enough since then to compensate not only
yourself but lesser-known artists who
contributed greatly to the blues
well that's kind of a loaded question
that to me but
i think that
first
that's yes there were a time that many
of the artists were not paid as maybe
they should have been
a person like b.b king
would have paid them to record
because i wanted to record so bad
so badly at that time
and i think many of the other artists
would have done the same
and i think a lot of those in all due
respect a lot of those uh companies were
good business people and if you didn't
ask they didn't give
and since that time
a lot of the young people today i i see
young people now the first thing you say
hey man yeah this is my music company
here you know this is my
production company so
you know what do you pay this is what i
want we didn't know that at that time
and i think a lot of us yes was
not paid what we should have been but i
don't always fault the companies
um before we ask the last question i
would like to present to you a
certificate of appreciation for
appearing here today you must have
houses full of things
not enough yet
and a national press club mug
thank you and thank you it has been
truly a pleasure thank you so much and
now for the last question
have you heard president clinton play
the saxophone
and if so how would you rate him as a
musician
they once told me that the boss
may not be right all the time but he's
the boss all the time
so the president is the president and
he's a good musician
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much
in a few minutes american perspectives
continues with a panel of los angeles
times journalists discussing politics
world affairs and the economy that's
after we look at some upcoming programs
sunday on book notes carlo